las fuerzas de seguridad siguen
presentes mientras los residentes hacen
vigilia en las calles de buffalo en el
estado de nueva york todos siguen
conmocionados después de que un joven de
18 años abriera fuego en el barrio el
pasado sábado
a estas personas aunque no estoy
relacionada con ellas siguen siendo
parte de mí son parte de mi comunidad
así que ahora mismo estoy de lucha
la policía lo atrapó sólo dejó que se
quitara el chaleco antibalas y saliera
del coche para detenerlo si hubiera sido
una persona negra no habrían matado a
tiros simplemente habrían disparado 100
veces
se entiende que el joven condujo durante
más de 300 kilómetros armado con un
rifle de asalto antes de llegar a
buffalo donde mató a 10 personas en el
interior de un supermercado la mayoría
de las cuales eran negras desde entonces
sería vinculado con un manifiesto de 180
páginas publicado en internet el
documento promueve una ideología
supremacista blanca y escribe planes
para atacar un barrio negro lo que llevó
al presidente joe biden a hacer un
llamado a la unidad
y el departamento de justicia ha
declarado públicamente que está
investigando el asunto como un crimen de
odio un acto de supremacía blanca y
extremismo violento con motivación
racial mientras lo hacen debemos
trabajar todos juntos para hacer frente
al odio que sigue siendo una mancha en
el alma de eeuu
quedan muchos interrogantes dentro del
ataque teniendo en cuenta que el joven
ya había estado en la mira por lanzar
una amenaza generalizada en su colegio
el año pasado